and we are live good evening good
afternoon good morning wherever you are
hell in the world and welcome to at
Stargate live special edition with our
friend Mack who um tell us about
yourself Mac really quickly and your
your little podcast okay I got more than
a little podcasts I have basically the
forever Adventure Network and under that
we have the MacGyver podcast which we
celebrate Richard Dean Anderson and all
of his iconic questions in MacGyver what
just a smidge yes
um some little twerpy looking guy along
blonde hair I've seen no not that guy
though
I have that which we talked about
Stargate MacGyver and you know life
stories and I also have a audio Series
where can you see
there it's the MacGyver sg1 audio series
which
the basic idea is that Jack O'Neill
finds out that he has a twin brother
um after the fifth Race episode and it
turns out MacGyver so I get to give us
new New Adventures of both shows
uh without contradicting anything like
as I would watch Stargate I'd go
I could see how MacGyver would fit into
this and plus that need as looking
forward to you want more of what you
love so that way I get to scratch and
itch and you can say it's Canon because
Sam mentions MacGyver repeatedly right
so I wrote that right in there too
that's like in episode two
um and then I have a more General
podcast called the never gets old
podcast which we celebrate pop culture
and TV movies and music and you know
it's it's more general for the general
audience but it's all Under the Forever
Adventure Network and there is a link at
the top of the description so please
Sidetrack just go and check Mac out and
he will
love you freaking dial you with sg1 but
we are here to talk about sg1 so let's
just run the intro then we'll get into
it
[Music]
oh
first of all we have a new
um member as well Ken Sutherland thank
you so so much for joining and becoming
a fully flight tonight Cricket you're an
absolute Legend sir
um got loads of people in uh Bob's in he
never goes away Laura is here travel
Malta that's a new one
um Mike you're in hello sir uh I love
MacGyver I have Sidetrack Quest sci-fi
Quest even and uh Bob again and so is
the it the SG-1 then
yeah okay
um I'm sure that means something I
forgot what it is so uh Sarah and Jordan
hello everybody hello everybody right so
I didn't read any of those comments I'm
so sorry but we will as we're going
along right
we're going to talk about Stargate right
yeah so we're going to talk about
Stargate because you actually talked
about my channel
I find it I think that's um better
protection I think you owe me like 50
Quid yeah if I ever make a cent doing
any of this you're welcome to all of it
but anyway you were very very kind about
my channel but you said one thing in a
video that made me go
I disagree but you said that it would be
very easy to bring a student back or
Auto Link Stargate back as general so
we're going to talk about that we also
though are going to discuss a little bit
the Jason Momoa idea I've had because
you are not a fan of that idea
we're also talking about that in my live
video tomorrow because the rest of my
people on my channel think it's a
terrible idea too yeah but it's it's all
connected connected and it's not a shot
at
the idea for that movie is great down
the road once we're established back
you then yeah do an offshoot do a do a
Ron index movie do uh like you had a the
same idea I did that once things get
going
by all means give us a show about this
or a special about oh yeah in the in the
Marvel way that they are giving so they
have movies and TV series influence each
other yeah I mean
golden age of I always say this we're in
a golden age of entertainment of things
that when I was a kid you couldn't even
comprehend the possibility of you know a
Thor movie or uh you know Ant-Man movie
okay sure
so we are getting
an abundance of quality stuff to to one
degree or another even if you didn't
love let's say secret Invasion that
miniseries which sure yeah but I'm still
thankful for it because it it's kind of
there to set up what comes in the future
by itself
though it was not great it was a slow
moving I didn't care about most of the
characters you know but in the overall
scheme I can go
I still appreciate the effort now at
least you have that big fight at the end
that made absolutely no logical sense
sure
tattoos are D are in your DNA by the way
so if ever I die my tattoo will appear
on whoever clones me because that's how
tattoos work but but you know remember
we're in that luxury that we get to say
comments like that you know what I mean
like like I'd rather I'd rather nitpick
for better quality
but still be thankful that they even did
it like like you know so quick we can we
can all agree that She-Hulk
shouldn't have been done that no come on
that was awful I
adore Daredevil so one of the best shows
right so the moment he came along
yeah at the moment he came along I'm
like
there there I don't care about the butt
shaking from shida or she she's the
owner
was awesome what's really cool to be
fair yeah
so you know again it's a luxury that we
as viewers have as long as we still
appreciate to help because otherwise
they're going to go oh you don't like it
done we're not gonna even try anymore
and now we're back to where we were 10
20 years ago gone yeah we didn't hate it
that much it didn't need to go away yeah
I appreciate that Marvel are trying to
do different things I just think they're
trying to do badly my problem with
Marvel with She-Hulk is my only real
problem with it is you've actually
watched the end the way they did the
whole fourth wall thing and unraveled it
none of this app series mattered at all
nothing that happened in that size here
has mattered
I have a problem with that what they
were trying to do was look at how we did
it with the comics that would break the
fourth wall so they thought they were
cute which I can tolerate except what
you just said
like the ending was kind of like all
right she talks to people in a room the
end
yeah you know I know it's cliche and she
says oh well we're supposed to have this
big battle I gotta tell you
in this case yeah give us a big battle
you can still do that conversation but
we do need to see some definitive ending
um
born again that's assuming it even
happens oh sure two or three things
there's a couple was it deadline or
variety two or three days ago and
they're saying that
they're not husband certain it's going
to get going again
they've been they've been filming and
they're like more than halfway done I
believe yeah they've got about three
episodes apparently in the back so um
editing and everything else you know as
far as the filming and not worried about
it I tell you honestly man nothing is
safe right now um Disney have just gone
and thrown that um
20 000 Leagues Under the Sea series that
cost 90 million dollars to make and
they've just got it we're not gonna put
on Disney right what did you do for them
like instead of getting panicky I just
go all right let's just wait for the
writer strike to end it'll it'll course
correct you know it just otherwise we're
gonna drive ourselves nuts going okay
just let it happen you know let them
fight the good fight eventually the
studio is gonna go you know what we
should probably just give people what
they want you know give the writers and
the actors what they want
so my opinion on stargate's return is
that not that it's complicated not that
it's necessarily difficult
but
we were very Advanced by the end of sg1
and I've always said I want Stargate I
don't want Star Trek
[Music]
so I think they have to come up with
quite a clever way
of of doing that because we were walking
with her I mean Brad Wright talked about
this is one of the reasons why he did
SGU because we were too damn Advanced
and he didn't know where the stories
were going
so that's why he thought there's no
peril
our weapons are too powerful and things
are too powerful we're just too powerful
so how do you move forwards
um
and I I think there are trip Falls there
I think there are things there that can
make it difficult if you're not very
clever if you're not very careful
what do you think about that okay that's
a writing issue which I have
that you can write that that's the
that's that's the opportunity not the
barrier we forgot Asgard core where'd
you put it damn it is it behind the city
where is it
no you could do a big catastrophe event
as a writer and there's your pilot uh to
you know even if it takes a whole season
to if that's the route they decide to go
to de-power them
great let that be the writing here's I
thought this out and to give you the
whole
from beginning to where we are now thing
we had done an episode on the MacGyver
podcast called the show Runners oath
and basically we celebrated what made
certain shows MacGyver Stargate I'm sure
there's others what made them legendary
and overall
the contributing factor was the
showrunner who knew to bring people
together who knew when does it wasn't
about his ego it wasn't about you know
an agenda it was about looking we're all
a team even down to the uh craft
Services I've had people from the shows
both shows say the exact same thing we
were all of One mindset that it wasn't
about us it was about us creating
and continuing the the
quality so as a matter of fact you'll
see a lot of shows go through the
sophomore slump
which means either these the
um
showrunner didn't have
a planned past season one because they
hadn't planned that far a lot or God
forbidden that I can give you examples
of this the show gets a new showrunner
who goes no I need to make my Mark I
need you guys to know that I am in
charge so I'm going to change some stuff
and the quality suffers so shows you
know Stephen Downing Brad Wright
perfect coincidentally a lot of the
MacGyver people ended up going to
Stargate which explains the continued
quality I love the cast and stuff did as
well I'm sorry I mean behind the scenes
people that
well it was well it was Richard Nelson's
it was heavily involved in production at
least to begin with with um Greenberg
obviously Greenberg Michael Greenberg
yeah night sweet guy
um so
now jump ahead now that you want to
revive a show
okay
two ways you can go about this you can
make the fatal error which 95 of the
time
don't do don't touch it won't work I
reboot
don't even don't even come to the table
walk away because you're telling the
audience even subconsciously we need you
to forget about what you love and accept
this new version
uh
I can only think of maybe five percent
of the time where that would have been
acceptable
in most cases you got to do the other
mostly final Stars probably the only one
isn't it
and technically if they had wanted to
they could have tied it to the original
but it wasn't necessary
yeah
um but again if you wanted to hedge your
bets you tie it to the original because
you already have a support percentage
that are going to watch it and support
it anyway even if you go from episode
one of the new series to crap you go
yeah but you did you're not asking us to
forget what we love and people will
resent you asking them to do that
so with the Revival
you need a couple things in place even
if you want to do your own thing you
have to tie it to the original
yeah let's say the cast is dead let's
say everybody involved in the original
was dead if you get somebody
passionate enough about the original
that can tie it to it let them do it
even if it's a sentence or a scene or
two and then you can move forward on
your own Easy people win
now
let's look at what makes a Revival
ideal
I don't care if it's Star Trek Quantum
Leap uh
did it pretty well
it's the continued story so even if they
go off the rails you're not asking us to
ignore the original yeah so for a
Revival here's what you need
as much of the cast back as you can
as much of the
people that were involved in the
original
uh
hopefully you can get the show runner
because they already have the mindset
and the experience
and at the very very very least if you
have none of that you need one of us
who is now in a position of executive
power who is a fan of said franchise
yeah so look at like it it's not about
me I don't need it to say
Mac Jackson you know above the credits
of a new say Stargate
you meet someone who's going to step in
and go I know what the executives want
I'm ready to fight for the quality that
made in this case Stargate iconic and
we're hoping we've got that guy because
we're hoping it's Mark Fergus well even
better
they were smart if the Amazon being
smart
right he's right there not only is he
right there
where's the freaking script
he's not like you gotta go Brad Brad
will you please come back he was ready
to go and he wrote the next thing which
I'm sure if okay you can discuss
he won't tell me he won't see me right
but if you don't tell me let's say they
have the meeting let's say he sits down
with Amazon and they go we like your
script except for this this and this
well he's not unreasonable as long as he
keeps the quality of the show
is going to go all right I can tweak
some stuff but you have the guy all
Amazon would have to do is oh we support
you we understand you know this do you
know why I actually don't think they are
he's involved and this is only my
opinion
During the period when Amazon before
Amazon bought MGM he was developing this
script and he's developing that script
for nearly a year
and he did keep
um let me just turn my phone off because
somebody's trying to get in touch with
me
um
a massive celebrity who's live right now
come on
anyway
um so another thing now that they keep
calling me that I look like um Rodney
McKay in the in the comments and I'm
going to ignore them
um you know the best Rodney episode
today anyway I'm watching this year at
the moment
um so
I actually think he was developing a
story and now what Brad even Brad didn't
know at the time was actually Amazon
were the ones that wanted the Stargate
show so they've actually approached MGM
and said we would love you to revive
Stargate and this is before
um they were the sound process was going
but before they'd even put bids in
whatever
um
Apple resumed the Apple were the people
that they thought they were Front
Runners so they were going to get it at
the time
so Amazon approach from the start of
this
it kept bouncing backwards and forwards
and Amazon kept bouncing it back and
going no that's not what we want that's
not what we want that's not what we want
and apparently it went back
several times in the end and but the
problem was apparently I spoke to one
person that was saying that they were
sort of
half in the conversation and apparently
things so Brad and MGM kept sort of
singing I mean Brad didn't know he was
talking to Amazon he was because he was
just talking through MGM but he kept
saying well what what do you want what
where do you want me to go and Amazon
couldn't answer they just kept saying
that it's not that it's something else
and that was the problem so now it feels
like I think there's two reasons why
Brad isn't involved they want to do a
movie and they don't think Brad's a
movie guy
and
they they feel like they gave him a
chance and it didn't work
here's the other problem
the people at Amazon
and and like you said Mark Fergus great
if you can't get Brad get mark because
because everything you've said through
all the videos that I watch and enjoy
he's the second best if you can't get
Brad get Mark great by all means
the prep the premise of starting a new
show is so open and obvious it you know
you're not
stuck you were never stuck
and any sort of like thing where you're
saying they're too powerful well that's
a writing opportunity there's your first
story arc de-power them make it creative
you know as long as you keep the premise
of what makes Stargate
the iconic show it was for eight years
and I know it's ten so yeah
um
right that's what I'm talking about
if if you keep those things it's not the
Stargate itself it's not the explosions
it's not the go it's the characters and
how they had the perfect cast that
gelled so well which is why I understand
it's an you want to do a new show you
want to bring in you know a younger cast
or whatever to keep it going by all
means but you need to start with your
originals and keep them around
even if when you bring in new characters
you can focus on them eventually but
make them part of it it all has to feel
like you're not being told guess what
here's your new Jack O'Neill here's your
new the audience won't go for it
I mean like this
this type of you know she's a nurse
she's a new scientisty lady yeah right
the audience won't buy it but if you do
it in such a way yeah that they're
welcome in you kind of like them on
their own and then you have Carter there
and Jax there then you're fine it's a
smooth transition the problem with
Amazon is in Jennifer's
see I learned things from watching your
channel
um as soon as you said her name I'm like
let's see if she's on Twitter
I don't think she's a she she was uh I
was I pounced on that I'm like please
listen to what we're saying anyway the
problem is they have an agenda of
thinking old school where a movie is
better than a TV series yeah that that
was true from the 50s to the early 90s
it's the additional way of reboot in a
series right right theories that's the
traditional one that might work see
a movie works for
an initial idea that isn't tested if you
didn't already have you know because you
got to do a quick two-hour story to give
you the basic idea premise even the
original Stargate movie never felt like
a full movie it felt like a um when I
tell people to get into Stargate I say
if you want to watch the movie you could
you don't have to it kind of feels like
a pilot for the TV show
so to go back to an already established
franchise which has so many hours behind
it such uh so many Dynamics you cannot
Encompass the general feel of what
Stargate is in a new movie where the
Amazon people don't care about us
because we're already hooked we're
already part of this
it's they want to get in their mind the
comic companies by the way do this the
same way they don't care about the
established readers or in this case the
viewers they want to get new people so
they think if we do a movie people will
no they're not because
if I didn't wasn't already invested I'm
not spending 14 per ticket to go to the
theater
and watch a movie on something that
maybe I'll love maybe I won't but
because of that uncertainty I don't care
if they give us everything we want in
that two hours look you and I if they'd
give us the perfect Stargate script
unfortunately the it will be known as a
financial bomb
because
the audience is already there and we're
waiting for it on TV if you're smart you
do the streaming thing like you said
give us a nice say 10 episodes to start
with give us our 10r mini series give us
a three hour mini series or something
exactly because now you're gonna set us
off and go look everybody
stargate's fine everything you love
they're still there they're still doing
the Stargate thing and look we got some
new people and you know and we can
swallow that easier with the reboots I
think with the Revival you've either
you've got to go two ways you've either
got to bring loads of the cash back and
and it'd be a Picard season three
Nostalgia where you'll have some new
characters but they're kind of
background and like you said you try and
push them forwards over time but you've
got to be really careful that because if
you start pushing old characters out we
won't like it I think
or you have to have almost no new
characters and maybe just a couple of
cameos because you don't want the old
characters to overshadow what you're
trying to do which is why with SGA they
brought through Rodney we love that
but he didn't overshadow the rest of the
what they were trying to do sort of
thing so you've got to go one of those
two ways you can't try and go half and
half or it just won't work right at the
moment it looks like they want to bring
back Sam and Daniel Michael Shanks and
Amanda Tapping I keep hearing Rick said
I'm all for it as long as it's connected
but yeah you know the movie all day do
an sg1 movie people [__] go crazy
well uh
we would go crazy but the theater thing
doesn't work it's no matter how great it
is it it if you do the miniseries even
like you said a three hour movie on TV
fine because you know no matter what
they do with O'Neill as long as they
don't do the cliche we gotta kill them
because now you're done I the audience
won't stand for that you can have them
still be a general no idea kill him I
think kill him no no because now you
just you just stomped on the crotch of
everybody that loves Stargate you you
kill him in him going out to Hero
who cares he's still gone he would still
be good it's he's the heart he's 85
years old or 88 years old he's the heart
of the show so now we're getting into
the writing stuff
what if Richard Dean Anderson says I
will come back for the movie but that's
it that's all I'm doing and I want to go
out on a bang got it you know retire him
I don't care no you don't kill people
the moment the moment you kill people
you limit your story you and you tick
off your audience
you know you always you as a writer you
always want to leave a window okay let's
say Richard Dean Anderson says which I
know he doesn't but let's just play the
scenario of he goes I don't want to come
back
he does but let's play that scenario out
you have to discuss him
and he's retired him and Sam
are happy Sam's there she can let you
know yeah Sam's or you know Jack's home
he's building a deck or whatever and
that way you always have the window
for a cameo down the road during season
nine and ten
okay here's my personal view on this
when Rick stepped away to be with his
daughter I love and respect him and he's
my idol for that yeah I get that but
they always had the opportunity to have
him come back
season 10 he goes hey guys
send him I can come back
I'm sorry now if you need me because
he's so humble he's not going to demand
anything he goes I'm free if you need me
and
most of the time he was wasted with the
wave at the door kind of you know the
200th episode they could have done more
with that anyway
well there you go so the third movie was
supposed to base around him he was
supposed to be right enough which okay
you can use those elements to do this
new whatever new series whatever
um but my point is you don't close the
door on opportunity no I say kill him
well that's that's bad I think as a
writer and if you want to have
an impact
there's a couple of things you can do
and killing a big star it I'm old I'm
only talking about if Richard Dean
Anderson says I will do the movie but
that's it
if he's if he says I'll do the movie and
yeah I might do a few cameos here and
there I'd be like [__] brilliant
happy days we've got Anil but if he was
to say look I want to do I'll do the
movie and you're going to pay me a nice
big paycheck but I don't that that'll do
me though I don't want to do any more
kill him it would have an emotional
impact it would have a story impact and
he ain't coming back anyway
yeah it would he because I know actors
who've changed their mind and also
you don't want your Heroes to be done
get him to ascend
sure
he can come back that's my point if you
kill him dead you've ticked off the
audience you've limited your future
possibilities the whole reason for my
audio series is to continue the
adventure you know what I mean so if you
kill him doing something that's that's
right I don't think it's necessarily
it's how you do it obviously I don't
think you have to tick off the audience
I think a lot of the audience would go
nuts on that but um but it would
definitely but I would love to see an
sg1 movie but let's talk about the movie
then because obviously I have this idea
that um it should be a Ron index movie
now I was doing that purely
from think about like if I was an
executive and I was about to earn a 200
million dollar check what would I do
right and what I would do is and this
again this is the traditional way of
doing it and I I think we can have an
argument about whether it's still
necessary to do this or whether it works
even in the current Cinema
but what you do is you sign an A-list
you get you get an a-lister
um and we've already heard rumors that
they've been trying to get a movie star
connected to this and they've [__] it
up a couple of times but they've tried
they've come that close to getting a
couple of people signed onto this and
they've ended up doing something else
but um
you get an a-lister you don't you can't
get any bigger a-lister right now than
Jason Momoa he is the man he is the
biggest the the biggest draw one of the
biggest draws in Hollywood
um and he was actually in the show
for me it's a no-brainer as a as a
two-hour advert
for what follows people I've had a few
comments saying that well you won't then
do the series I don't want him to do the
series
I want him to do the movie because I
want
non-gaters to go
I want that movie to be number one in
the chart that in the first opening
weekend
Stargate sg1 movie however much Gators
would go freaking crazy and probably go
and watch it two or three times
anybody that didn't watch Stargate ain't
watching that film I won't go
am I wrong
unfortunately yeah I understand again I
understand what you're trying for well
no I understand what you're trying for
and I
again you said it yourself you're
thinking like an Amazon executive that's
what I've tried to do yeah all right
don't don't because again if even if
they gave us exactly what we wanted with
the perfect Stargate movie
the return for a movie
will not pay out it will be known as a
flop not the quality not the quality I
know what you mean because I'm a moment
they're probably going to want to spend
200 million dollars on it and so you
don't want to you know the Amazon people
are oh how can we trick the the audience
these new people to come in
Stargate is known and loved by new
audiences every day why because of
people like you and me who go guys do
you want to know what the perfect series
is
and now we talk about it and we have
kept this alive since it went off the
air unfortunately
it's not because we're stubborn it's
because we just want people to enjoy the
greatness that we already enjoy
so first of all
if you if you keep going down not you
the the Amazon people if you keep going
down the
trail of it has to be a movie it has to
be a movie it has to be a movie you're
done before you even began I'm sorry
Amazon people it's a flawed thing you
you've limited your audience you're
asking too much of a stranger and you
want them to jump on a a franchise
that's however many years old
you oh and you want them to leave their
house spend however much money on a
chance
if you make something that they can
watch at their leisure in their house
that people have talked about and maybe
maybe they do enough
um commercial press for it
I am much more likely to give something
a shot and I'll give you a perfect
example
all my life I've heard about Doctor Who
I had a I had a girlfriend when I was a
kid that loved watching it on 44. and
these are the baker years these are the
you know and I remember sitting there
going okay so give me wait he's a doctor
why is he a doctor okay what tardis okay
and she would kind of you know give you
the answers but it never quite made
sense so now the 50th Anniversary comes
about with 10 and 11 and it's a team up
and I'm a sucker for time travel I'm a
sucker for a team up a crossover they're
brilliant yeah no they were I don't know
if they did in England or not
but it was supposed to have a studio
sort of they were going to put it out in
a movie theater yeah three pounds in
theater had they done that here as much
as I may have loved it I wouldn't go to
the theater to try something new
especially something with that much
history to it what I did was I waited
for it to come out
I thought okay so if this is the one
that's gonna hook me this this David
Tennant guy seems awfully Charming
and I watched and I watched it and now
we are a family of whovians I started
watching it my kids sat down and you
know we've gone backwards forwards we
are all caught up
but the idea was
I wasn't going to the theater I was in
my home and I went all right this seems
like a good jumping on point let me give
this a try and then I can always go
backwards to be fair here they put it in
theaters the day before for one night
and then it was on the BBC the big
Saturday night thing so it was just
because it was a it wasn't trying to get
a theater release it was because people
were so excited about it they were like
do you want to watch it at the cinema I
don't want them right on the BBC the
next day so um it's not quite the same
thing but what I was saying is that is
your argument then sorry that against
sort of like doing a Jason Momo movie
that you don't want to see a movie
it's more than that it's more than that
you it's okay we haven't got a choice
because anyway we haven't if Jennifer
Mulkey says movie
90 of us don't want to move you first
I've every poll I've ever put out 90 no
thank you I just want a bloody series
and I'm and I'm one of them I don't want
a movie I think it's a stupid idea good
um but it looks like that's what we're
getting
here's here's the other problem with
that Jason Momoa thing go for it
okay
Stargate sg1
is such a fantastic perfect show because
of the cast being so gelled but you can
do you can imagine these people on their
own having more there's a lot of layers
to these characters
people like Rodney
and Ronan Dex are great
as a piece of the pie
but on their own they're only limited to
so much like I don't want to watch two
hours of Rodney I don't want to watch
definitely two hours of ronin Dex who is
such a you know it's a cliche character
people love that cliche but you know
it's a very one note I'm The Wookie I'm
the guy I shoot guns and I talk tough
great
that's great you're part of the team
though so you add that element but on
your own it's too much to ask of an
audience and we've had
trillions of movies of the tough guy
running through the city or the woods
shooting at bad guys you know Rambo
Commando Etc
I think it's not a fair representation
of what Stargate as a whole is now for
you and I once they get going with this
franchise again
go ahead I don't care if it's theater I
don't care if it's a mini series I don't
care if it's whatever you could do your
Ronan deck story but I'll stand there
and cheer
but to go we're putting all our eggs
in this bowl to say
new people this is Stargate no it's not
no it's no I wouldn't I don't argue that
it's not stocking I don't think it would
be right and that's the problem what I'm
saying is if we do a Stargate movie will
non-gaters go to watch it no
I've spent time with Jason Momoa I love
Jason Momoa
uh however we're going to be getting
Aquaman 2 which looks like it's
fantastic it will not do well
oh yeah he looks awful but I highlighted
the first one Jason Momo was brilliant
terrible movie sure but let's assume you
love everything Aquaman yeah
um
it will not
it comes down to a basic under a
misunderstanding of what movies are
on a studio level
that they don't they're not changing
with the times they're still thinking
movies are better than TV shows yeah
you're flawed from the beginning so the
lines are blurred tomorrow now aren't
they exactly with screaming the blue the
lines are blurred the problem is
people don't go to the cinema because
they'll be like oh they're on a
streaming service in a couple of months
I think there is an element to that
there are definitely oh without a doubt
and like I said movies can work for a
new premise
a new you know this is some new idea
that there isn't a television there's
not a franchise there's not so many
years behind it by all means try it try
a movie let's see what happens maybe
it'll become a TV show with a franchise
though a franchise we're so lucky we
have three series you know miniseries we
got stuff in the past you're already
past what you want a movie to do you're
way past it it would be such a step
backwards to do a movie like let's let's
save a movie as
um an extra an extra if you want to
throw it out whether it's theater
whether it's TV let it be part of the
franchise but you cannot hang everything
on a movie whoever it is Jesus you know
uh Clint Eastwood I don't care if you
get the original cast from the you know
Kurt Russell I remember you guys talking
about that
it's not your the audience won't go for
it you need to remember what Stargate is
it's it's this group and we don't need
the flashy explosions we don't need the
gun bat we need the dynamic of these
core people
you could have taken those four
characters and more but I'm focused on
just the four you could have put those
characters in any setup and you still
would have loved it it's it wasn't a
swoosh of the gate that made me watch it
it was Richard Dean Henderson and then I
went oh everybody else is excellent too
they're all
deep characters great actors you know I
love the way they gel it feels like
friends you kind of can predict how Jack
would react to this and Sam would react
to that
you can't shove that in a two-hour movie
well that's the problem that's why
they'll end up that's why the Jason Momo
movie is a better idea but anyway you
think I just think it's apparently
because people will go and watch a Jason
Momoa movie and again the way Amazon
thinks they'll think that's a say for
bet and then they're gone that's the
right thing yeah we saw all right I
liked Jason
I'm just saying that's what they would
think but anyway oh yeah yeah yeah
um what we think we know that's not what
they're doing anyway
right so from what we think we know it
is going to be a movie it is going to be
very quickly followed by a series
yeah that's the thing too is it promised
because if they that's the other mistake
of doing a movie if they go well the
movie did terrible so we're gonna scrap
the idea of bringing a series ah you
know the suggestion is and again none of
these things are promised because of the
strikes sure if it wasn't for the
strikes and we were three months ago I
would say I am 95 certain from the
people I've spoken to that we're going
to get a movie that Within
three or four months will be followed by
a series because they're going to be
filming them together
um pretty much but I want the movie
first as the two-hour advert for what
then follows because they want the
cinema still does have an element of
prestige it is still of this Cinema and
Amazon are desperate for attention
basically they want to be seen as the
grown-up
um you know a studio they don't want to
be seen as the the streaming service
anymore they want to be a grown-up
Studio yeah they could do I just know
that's why they've bought MGM think
about this
do your three to ten episode mini series
follow directly by the movie
that I think is the smarter way to go
that way okay Jennifer sulky you still
get your movie you happy but you already
made the audience happy beforehand
because you gave us a series and now go
ahead again after you do your series
whatever comes after is bonus it's gravy
you know
that I would I'll tell you something if
you give us a good 10 episode Stargate
sg1 series that re-establishes us and
makes us happy and comfortable
go ahead let your movie be a Jason Momoa
Thing by all means because now you've
already gave gave us what we need not
just want what we need and the on the
home audience that would have gone to
the theater already saw your episodes
well talking to somebody I spoke to
um who is a PR guy
the the
opinion is that Amazon want the movie
because they said they want the splash
they want the posters they want all that
sort of thing they want the adverts they
want the trailers they want people to be
talking about this for 12 months
the series will come really quickly
after it because it's going to be
connected to the movie and that the
movie will be an sg1 Revival
right it'll have a small budget
relatively so I've been talking 70 to 80
million dollars is the is the rough
budget but when you're not spending 20
or 30 million dollars of that budget on
A-list Stars I think that makes you you
or you get a lot of that money on the on
the screen
and because they're going to be filming
this
in two or three sound stages in um I
believe it's going to be in Canada again
or in Eastern Europe actually the last
thing we heard
um that um these things are going to be
formed so it's 70 80 million dollar
budget for the movie but then you've got
a 50 million dollar budget for the
series but you're using the same sets
you're really you can you know you can
move money around so you can spend 10
million dollars on the series that you
then use on the movie and vice versa
sort of thing so instead really what
you've got to think about it is instead
it's
150 million dollars on a movie and the
series because they share everything so
I think it's actually very good and we
get a lot more value for money that way
because they're not taking sets down
putting sets up reading yeah blah blah
blah oh it's brilliant and again I'm up
on all your videos every time you post
some some sort of Stargate you're like
oh first thing in the morning I gotta
hear what what the latest you know it
gets me all excited and those type of
reports give me hope because it seems
like you know once they get past the
understanding what Stargate is and
putting the right people in place that
is so brilliant well that's what they
did with the original you had Atlantis
nsg1 filming and they could walk across
the room and do you know cameos or
whatever
we love that stuff that is such a simple
easy
gratifying thing for the audience I
think from a business point of view as
well it's just like that's efficient I
like efficiency in my job I like
everything I hate doing things twice and
I'm just like yeah that would be you'd
have like the Stargate Hub and it's like
these three or four sound stages I'm
just gonna write we're just doing
Stargate now
we're going to do a little mini series
we're going to do a couple of movies we
might go straight to Prime movie blah
blah blah
um and just crap that is so exciting if
they just get the easy easy premise
right of starting us up again and like I
said it's there there was nothing broken
before uh as far as you know
restrictions great set us up with what
you need to have happen and what you
definitely don't want to have happen
there's so much room between there to
write brilliant stuff
yeah you know I I I agree it's it's so
it is simple in lots of ways I do think
there is it's complicated because of the
technology and how advanced we are but
again I I know what you're saying it's a
writing problem but I think like that
and I think how would I get around that
which is great because you know what if
you're thinking it that means the
writers are going okay wait a minute
Whoa We Gotta Do a deal for everybody
all right well here's your story arc
something catastrous some sort of
catastrophe makes everything not or not
everything but let's say they lose the
um
the asgard's power okay something
happens that makes that defunct oh crap
well now you've also set up your big bad
you know if they're that powerful to
wipe out all this power we have now what
what do you do I mean that was one of
the things that I did enjoy about season
9 and 10 despite all the other problems
I had was the villains were cool like
that was a that was a philosophical
problem they were so uh powerful you
know and they didn't understand where
the power was coming from oh God that
that set I remember being impressed by
that because if you're not going to do
the ghoul well how do you up that oh
that's how
you know we actually had um I can't
remember if one of us came I think
Harris came up with it I forget now but
one of the story ideas became was just
like kicking balls around was that um
there was a um there was basically some
Anubis worshipers
and they had figured out a way or got a
machine
I think the way it was described is like
it was an Anubis magnet
kind of thing so it would because you
know he's obviously fighting
um with uh it's I always forget I always
mix up Osama and the other one I always
mix up the one that's fighting Anubis
and the one that's fighting
um and Andrew always make sure but
anyway so he's fighting
um the thing so basically it was to pull
anubis's ascended being back onto our
plane
because that's an sg1 problem
um so they brought
um O'Neill in and they would the idea
was that they were supposed to
figure it all out and stop them from
bringing Anubis back sure but they fail
um Anubis comes back and then I think we
said sort of like yeah we'll kill Jack
saving a bunch of kids or something
um and then that would be the perfect
idea for a movie
I think five years ago Amazon would have
gone he had taken a piss and I actually
genuinely think five years ago they'd
have gone no we need to do we need to
get Jason Momo we need to do a Ron index
movie
but then things like Picard season 3
happen
and then I genuinely think Amazon are
looking at going
we don't need to do that we don't need
to give Jason Momo 20 million dollars
because we can give Michael Shanks a
hundred and fifty thousand dollars okay
RDA might want a bit more than that but
you know we can do this and we can bring
in and actually fans won't just go to
watch that movie they will go and watch
it twice and they will be rolling around
in the aisle screaming and yelling and
going nuts
um and there is so much interest
in Stargate online
um Star Trek is the most searched Sci-Fi
show
um then Star Wars and then Stargate
Stargate hasn't been on my screen for 15
years
most search things yeah yeah but no it's
so I mean I just think if you did and
that was just one idea off top of a head
there's a million
related to something that happened to
sg1 that you have to then bring Jack
back because they're the only ones that
can solve the problem
Maverick Top Gun it's that idea exactly
see so either he's still a general or
he's retired I don't care it doesn't
matter because
if you want to put them back in the Box
afterwards for whatever reason big
mistake but let's you know whatever okay
then it goes back to retirement which
means he can always come forward again
he has the ascended Gene but he also is
one of the most powerful with the
ascended Gene you know what I mean like
he was the one they're like no you were
the one that we were looking at because
you're something special besides anybody
else that had the gene in them Jack has
power that he doesn't even realize he
has replicates his head and he says your
your brain is much more powerful than we
realized and that's not my first time
um
yeah I mean so so the way I do it at the
moment in my story
because I do I do episodes that take
place
during Stargate SG-1 years but then I
also do stuff that happens today
so
you got to remember
what is it what's the saying uh hates a
vacuum
the power power hates a vacuum or spaces
so they always say that okay we took
down all the system Lords
but there's random guys out there who
weren't in charge but could be now so
they can be fighting amongst themselves
next thing you know you know sg1 sitting
around going oh we're just exploring we
don't have anything to worry about and
Out of the Shadows comes a bunch of new
Gould if you want to go back to the you
know what we know and love and if that
feels if Amazon feels safe bringing back
the original baddies that's how you do
it you go oh crap
this little guy who we didn't even care
about you know molleth or whatever his
name was oh God he's got power now
because remember they were so smart they
would lay the groundwork for potential
bad guys when they were writing and
they'd say well whatever happened we
don't know he disappeared and they move
on to the rest of the episode
use them I I can imagine a wall at Brad
Wright's office full of little Post-it
notes with don't forget that bad guy
right because talking to a couple of
people his writing method is just sit
down and write and he says how did you
get there I don't know she's just I just
found my way yes
um one of the guys on who said that you
know you could tell or I said you could
tell during season four going forward
they were at a part where they went you
know what we've set enough groundwork
let's have fun let's see what happens in
this episode if like Paul melosi was one
of them he
what if we give them super powers well
how are we gonna do that aha the
armbands you know what happens if we do
that and and you could tell like the
Groundhog Day episode the time loop it's
it's that's fun but they did it in such
a way that you didn't feel like they
were ripping off no it felt like
inspired or an homage to sometimes but
they they did that I mean brilliant they
were very open honest about it no sir we
can't call it the Enterprise they were
always doing things little things like
that and little nods but also it's a
it's a Sci-Fi show where they had
220 something episodes of course there's
gonna have episodes that you think oh I
remember a Star Trek episode like this
so I remember belts
of Reason Jack was always the one to go
oh come on you know what who talks like
that he was always the US which is why
he's he was such a key dynamic
that when he had to leave in season nine
I thought okay
My Hope was that it was going to be as
good as say an episode previously where
he wasn't in it you know what I mean
okay because the rest of the cast is
still solid and great but I knew going
into these that boy you need that
Dynamic he is he is that piece of the
four sliced pie
you know that that you need so if they
can bring him back
do that like have him in this new thing
you know for whatever extent he wants to
be part of it because again he keeps
saying no I actually do I I if it's it's
not a reboot I will be in it
variously like they did we're doing
um with SGU and SGU to get like you said
so slow in the beginning
and then they got better and then they
you go okay now you're running now this
is good okay well when they had Jack in
towards one of the last episodes where
he uses the stones and comes on board
you know you get the O'Neill irreverence
like Corporal
and little things like he starts walking
in the wrong direction that's great
you know you just you need that
yeah and a lot of it was a lot of it was
Rick adliby which you can't write for
you just kind of go
we can keep that yeah we're going to
keep that yeah
a lot of the time the writers were
pulling their damn hair out
and and
lose I'm sorry Joe Flanagan I
if you know this since you you always
get the scoop scoop let me see if you
know this
I was talking to Michael Shanks at a
convention uh years ago and it was
during season nine
I was at a convention with him he sit
next to me and you know because they
would come around to the tables and and
socialize until somebody comes over and
goes you gotta move to go to the next
table Yeah but if you're lucky you get
someone on one time to shoot the ball
and I mentioned about how
man they really didn't do jack a service
they just he's not there they never
explained where he went you had to read
online that he's had a home World
security
but they failed to give us the the
respect to give us Jack
even in conversation there were episodes
in season 9 or 10 where you go clearly
Jack would be mentioned right now you're
you're making an effort to not mention
Jack yeah so Michael shakes goes
wait a minute what did they show I said
in the premiere of the ninth season is
it only in these couple scenes he goes
we filmed a half hour's worth of story
which was Jack getting the news of oh
crap something has to change because the
ioa
is getting more powerful and if he
doesn't go to Washington he has to be
our voice to fight against them and it's
him dealing with the whole I don't want
to leave this I love this and making
that sacrifice
for the greater good plus he's has some
one-on-one with each member and they
give him a decent you know bon voyage
they filmed it he said they didn't use
it
I'm like well guess what it shows
because the audience it was still
surgery yeah yeah you know
and for me
I I knew there was going to be a
difference
um with Richard Dean Anderson not being
in front of the camera I knew that and I
was willing to accept that what I didn't
understand which I do now was where you
could feel the difference of him not
being behind the camera because he was
the guy that would sit there and go no
we can't do that that scene doesn't work
you know we we can't do the we can't do
the cliche characters
you know if it's if it's too easy the
audience is gonna know and the moment
that he wasn't there boy I could tell
you
in every episode of at least season nine
I could my wife and I would go there
right there Ricky said something because
this scene doesn't make sense this
doesn't work
so I never I love Richard Dean Anderson
um to death and but um I think the show
just evolved and I I think of season 9
and 10 like
I love Claudia Black I loved I loved
what they did
um and I love that that the RDA jumped
in and out I know around Seasons eight
there was some tension
between RDA and a couple of the
producers well because he kept being
called away I got some info on that he
didn't want to he didn't want to have to
go I can't be in this episode I have to
you know
he had some crap going on in his family
where you know he's like
he taught
I talked to him one time at a convention
he had kind of let out his frustration
of you know yeah yeah I had some family
crap going on people were doing some
stuff out of spite making my life more
difficult and so the reason he stepped
back in season nine was because he's
like all right I can't keep doing this
to the Stargate people that he thinks of
like family he goes I'll make a
sacrifice and step away he didn't want
to but again for his daughter yeah
family first yeah he but but again to
this day he's like
he's resentful that he had to go through
that he mentioned something that I serve
in I can't remember what his name I'd
like I've never met him you have
obviously but obviously an interview and
he did there was some discussion oh no
actually I spoke to somebody that told
me about this actually that said he he
did
very publicly he actually told Brad that
I just don't know where my character's
going
so I do want to step step back a little
bit
um and that yes it was because he wanted
his family and stuff but partly it was
because he just didn't
he thought he'd done everything with
Jack but he could do and he wanted to
and I think he's got a brain as well
that he knows look this character would
he would be a general now he would be I
think this doesn't is starting to not
make sense
there's never one reason for these
things and trying to
tune him in and that's why they promoted
him as a general and that way he could
still be there when he could be there
and but at the same time once the drama
in his life was over which I you know I
love and respect his
um
privacy that that he's done very well at
it makes it hard to connect with them
but
he keeps his private life private
uh once that was wrapped up towards the
end of season nine
I was thrilled for him but then good
good now he's available let's let's use
him and they didn't
the thing about he was very heavily with
the charity work by that point as well
and I know that was taken up a lot of
his time as well and it was he was
really getting that off the ground and
he um he for years he wouldn't do
conventions not that he didn't want to
do them but he he always said I want two
things I want the money that I make from
these things to go to the charity
because I don't need the money
I'm doing this because I want to connect
with people and I want you have to
guarantee me at least five minutes per
person
and for years convention people would
say no he's like what do you mean no you
it's a win-win and then eventually
right
I mean can you imagine we could have met
him like years before and now somebody
goes yeah we could do that sure five
minutes yeah and I love that he
guarantees
you're mine for at least five minutes
you know that's perfect and the fact
that he gives all the money away also
great
you know so Alexa is man I know I know
how important the maritime and all the
things the charity work he does is
because of Any he talks about it so much
um and and we've donated our channel has
been able to we've donated a little bit
of our income every month and we've I've
donated across to that sort of thing
because every month
I can't think the internet actually so
is this going to go to the Jamie wants a
new bike fund
right
um
you'll ask for charity behind you in a
couple episodes there'll be like a
gold-mounted you know bike or something
hanging from the wall and you're like oh
that did that show up I'm sorry let's do
this charity donation I got so I've got
some gold rooms for my bike
um
but uh We've I'm doing something for the
actual
guys on the channel soon so we're gonna
we're gonna get some nice t-shirts done
and we're gonna give them have a bit of
a giveaway and we've got a big star gate
related hopefully event coming up that
we're gonna really shout from the
rooftops and make you guys very very
excited I'll tell you I I know I've told
you this already but I really appreciate
I said it on my show I always appreciate
how you're keeping everybody up with the
latest news but also how you don't go
this is guaranteed like you always know
it's rumor like you're smart enough to
go I'm telling you only what I've heard
like you know a lot of people will
say no this is a guarantee and then they
look like idiots three weeks down the
road well the problem is what I learned
very early on was stuff changes
so even if it's true when I say it
um it might not be true a week later
basically until it's done I'm actually
not even even when a show is done
nowadays it doesn't mean we're ever
gonna see it but that girl was 95 done
yeah so I mean it's it's and the problem
is
a big problem with the whole star deck
not just Stargate though all the
different things we're looking at
getting from MGM in the next couple of
years
um is that there's a lot of infighting
going on
um and I know um Jennifer
um Steve and Jenny stiven who's a really
good friend of the channel and who used
to work on MGM and has done I used to
work at Stargate Commander
she talks about this a lot this because
there's there's Executives at MGM that
are still in control and still have
some Authority sort of thing
and they really really don't like what
Amazon's plans are they really are
fighting
but there are there are people within
Amazon
to have like the Brad right thing
we know bringing Brad writing is a
no-brainer if all the Gators know that
that's a no-brainer and I talk about the
rings of power problem quite a lot and
that's one of the things that they've
just said that what they that what they
desperately don't want is a load of
hatred about the third most searched
Sci-Fi show on on the internet they
don't want to load of hatred before it
comes out
the Ring's a power problem that all of
these YouTubers are gonna go this is
woke garbage and this and just and
everybody just turns off it before it
even comes before it's even made
something so they want to avoid that
who is going The Babylon 5 reboot is
supposedly going to be we're going to be
getting that after the strikes um a hard
reboot of Babylon 5. but J Michael
zielinski is writing it the original
Creator and he is going to be heavily
involved in it so it sort of takes the
wind out of the sails of anybody going
this is going to be a load of garbage
because the fans will be going yeah but
JMS is right in it so right it takes the
wind out of the sails get Brad involved
it doesn't matter on what level get Brad
involved and it's done but there are
people at Amazon and MGM that agree with
us
the problem is Jennifer saki doesn't
right and that's the thing about either
missing the point not being a fan of the
franchise as you should or it's Eco a
lot of that is ego everybody wants to
make sure that you they know or they
want the world to know what they've done
so that way
I actually don't think it is no I don't
mean her in particular I just mean I
know you mean the honest reason why I
think she's going for movie is actually
because she doesn't particularly care
she is just a manager in her head she's
like right this is a very valuable
resource that we have now we bought mgm4
things like this
Stargate was the it's behind Bond props
Target is probably the most valuable
thing MGM own there's really only
Stargate Bond Rambo Rocky
RoboCop I'm struggling for that
franchises some sort of stuff that's
franchiseable they're the valuable
things but really the top three of those
is is Rambo uh sorry Rocky Creed Rocky
Creed sort of thing Stargate and bond
um so they have to do it but in Jennifer
sulky's head she's just his manager
going well if we want to Kickstart a
franchise you do that with a movie
because that's what you do
and we've got one billion dollars a year
put aside for movies
so let's do that see that's it doesn't
go beyond that with the red it's
stubborn it's that stubborn I think I
know better that's simple as that yeah I
think I know better and I'm not gonna
budge but wait a minute the guys who can
handle all of what you want
and give you your movie are right there
just allow go here do it do do your
thing because we know it's proven
success do your thing and we'll back you
and then once they prove themselves
then you could do your movies you could
do your whatever I don't care if they do
a freaking musical at that point
let's go crazy
I said that because I know I remember
those don't trigger me
um
when we get to 200 episodes they can do
whatever they want but you understand
what I'm saying I mean yeah if you get
to 200 episodes well that's beyond
proof you know what I mean that's just
get us back to what we know it's already
there you got the people let it happen
stop stopping progress you're halting
the progress that is so easy to do with
this franchise
more than any other would you agree
more than any other friend tonight
because one of the nice things about uh
Star Wars maybe less a degree but Star
Trek
has been so confused and I did I did a
video talking about the other day
because the timelines are all confused
and what's Canon is confused and
um where we are and it's just conf
because there's been so much of it by so
many different people and you mentioned
it earlier a new Creator will come in
and go I want to do something my way
which is just always the most maddening
thing
how many movies have been ruined because
the director changes halfway through I'm
going to do something my I don't like
that I'm going to do this I'm going to
say well that's how we get crap films
but
um so when we get the new whatever it is
with Stargate it's not confused we've
got
10 seasons of sg1 that is I can't really
think of many times they stepped on
Canon
right um
SGA didn't there's you know it's it's
really good and SGU obviously only had
two seasons they didn't have time but um
I really don't think I think from that
point of view let's say Star Wars
they haven't either I don't think even
though they have I mean if you actually
talk to Star Wars fans they'll go are
you crazy they've changed so much I'm
not big I'm not a massive Star Wars fan
I care a little but there's all the
cartoons and things that they've kept to
in this way but my main thing is just
Star Wars is they've done everything
like Tatooine they've got a whole
universe there to explore they haven't
bothered so if they did that Star Trek
same thing got a whole university keep
making stuff on the Enterprise I don't
know why Stargate they just mustn't make
that mistake they don't have to do
the problem is it's a very simple
formula Stargate sg1 and SGA had a very
simple formula
um you've got a place SGC or Atlantis
you've got teams you've got the gate we
go and explore stuff happens it's not
that complicated right we have a few
different Dynamics in the characters not
that complicated right it doesn't have
to be complicated no not at all we've
got a massive Universe there to explore
go and explore it
I saw the um
the role-playing game that they're
coming out with
okay so there's a video about
timekeepers I keep forgetting there's a
video on on YouTube of them
playing it starting it up and the basic
idea of that was they're not touching
the SGC this was a side project
and okay the moment you went it's
connected but it's its own thing well
now you're not trampling on anybody
Stargate gives you that as you know from
the the just our ideas alone you can
very easily bring us back to the SGC you
can have the Stargate and the Pentagon
which they never officially said
remember that the Universe apparently
online they're like it's supposed to be
in somewhere in the Pentagon well they
never said it so for all I know it's
still at the SGC under NORAD you know
you could do so much and never trample
on
anything that happened before it's so
open it's so open I like I hate prequels
but Stargate is screaming out for a pre
you know years down the line once we've
had a series or two or anything but
we're screaming out for an ancients
prequel something that actually adds
to the story and would be interesting
still and I hate prequels hate them
generally they pee on Canon and they
ruin everything but starve it because
you can do a you can do a prequel series
it's five million years ago
exactly idiot is a writer if you then
pissed on Canon if you've got five
million years back
next I've got a mosquito and now
everything's dinosaurs exactly because
oh we forgot about that we forgot to
invent the Stargates like or something
just stupid
um oh you know you you do an episode
that then disagrees with something that
happened in because they never really
talked about the Ancients that much not
really and details I mean
um actual like points of fact that we
know happen sort of thing we have lots
of rumor and stuff with the anxious but
there's not that many so you could
probably on a couple of sides of paper
say everything we actually know for fact
about the um ancients that any
that from the series sorry that you
that's kind of you can't mess with that
now you'd be a [__] to then do
something in a prequel series that you
know that contradicted something in sg1
sure because there was a lot much yeah
and and you know back to your initial
question with the title of this episode
it's super easy to bring it back but the
the the the the
potential
after you do however many episodes if
you do it right which isn't that
difficult so massive you can go forward
in history you can go back in history
it it
it's staggering like I I love thank you
again for having me on because not only
do I uh appreciate you I appreciate
the conversations and the subject that
you guys bring up but at the same time
I'm watching it going
ah oh I wish I was right there
you know like no you're missing this
idea you're missing you know
and I I I'm thrilled to to challenge
there's always something and always a
different opinion and we love that we
love bringing opinions
onto these things and I mean obviously
as long as you understand that you are
wrong and I'm right because you know I'm
in charge then you know that's as long
as we understand that
that seems to be your catchphrase
because that's that's very interesting
now this is a place we're supposed to be
coming and like exploring ideas and like
say I I generally have always thought
that it's very very difficult to bring
back Stargate but the more we talk about
it and the more I try one thing I
actually think no it's it doesn't have
to be because you can set a series on a
Stargate an sg1 team just go through the
gate yeah okay this spaceship is still
there it's fine you you carry on and you
you do the story but then you can do a
series in a couple of years or a mini
series or something aboard the Hammond
yeah more of a star Trekkie High concept
big Sci-Fi series you can have an
episode with a runner that's just
running around the woods exactly with no
technology at all if you wanted to be
one of the best episodes that they've
ever made you know like massive universe
that we can explore in lots and lots of
different ways so actually yeah even
though I've talked about in the past how
I think they need to be very careful
the way to be careful is just to focus
on
certain aspects of the universe for
different things and not try to do
anything that's too
big at their first at least and then you
can grow do you want Marblehead
you start small and you build
any space has the audience is there to
go on that Journey as long as you start
us off on what we want and what we
already know
easy then once you establish that and
you tell the audience you're safe we get
it we know what you want here it is
everything's back the way you want it
then no matter what you do afterwards
you know back to what I said about the
um the god-awful anything that's a
reboot is typically a spit in the face
to the established audience
one of the reasons I I decided to push
forward and create the audio series
was because we had been doing episodes
uh discussing the god-awful
reboot of MacGyver which was MacGyver in
name only there was nothing MacGyver
about it at all
and one of the you know most in most
cases if you don't like something don't
watch it right isn't that the the final
say however however I found there's a
loophole if you're a guy
who has a podcast you have to watch even
the most god-awful thing because if
MacGyver is on it I have to be able to
discuss it with people who want to
discuss it with me and give my fair
opinion which means I have to be
knowledgeable of it so weekend week out
I would sit there and I'd watch it and
I'd try to just I would say okay what if
I look at it as its own thing what if
there had never been a MacGyver before
Oh no this is still God awful and we
would discuss it and it got down to the
point where I went if you're gonna
complain about something
fair or not the next step is what are
you going to do about it
yeah because otherwise you're just a
whiny baby going I don't like it well if
I create something that gives people an
alternative
now I feel like there so now I get to
complain I'll tell you what if the
Stargate movie comes out and I go to the
cinema and watch it and I don't like it
you are going to see me being like a
crying baby
[Music]
have me on again and we'll both cry
together because I'll be with you but
like a perfect example of how they could
have tied it in you could have had this
new MacGyver show no matter how garbage
it was they could have very easily said
this is his son or his grandson
and then you know now no matter what
they do afterwards it's its own thing
and I talked to Peter linkoff before the
show aired he had actually contacted me
and we we're going back and forth and I
was trying to give him the heads up of
this is how you do it bud you want to
make everybody happy you gotta tie it
into the original and he went um we're
not doing that this is for a new
generation and I'm like no MacGyver
isn't stuck it's a timeless
it's one of those great Timeless shows
the message is always current everybody
makes the joke about MacGyver in a thing
a nuclear weapon's about to go off give
me some gaffer tape and a knitting
needle yeah
right and that's cool that is legendary
that is such a compliment to hear all
the time so he went no I'm not going to
listen I'm going to do my own thing so
then the show premieres and I watch it
and we do an episode and I'm fair but I
go this is not MacGyver this is and
guess what he blocks me he's like I you
didn't you're not gonna praise me
because they thought that I would be the
show that would be their free commercial
yeah
no
no you missed the point
by this point I'm not going to do that
when it comes to stargo yeah if they had
tied it in had they tied this in
then you could have gone well it's
garbage but you're not asking people to
ignore what they love
and I think that's important and that's
I mean I think that's why the Quantum
Leap was quite clever even though like I
say I got through about half the season
and I gave up a little bit but it was
quite clever and they tied it they
created a new show
but that was the overarching story that
tied back into the original and you also
leave the door open for Scott Bakula to
come back which is always good right
from where everything we know with
Stargate though Amazon are not going to
do a hard reboot they have absolutely no
intention
um but a little caveat on that I'll tell
you who the rumored director is off air
because I don't want to I can't say it
on a
[Music]
nobody will ever know because well one I
forgot them but
apparently the director that is not
signed on because he refuses to sign on
until the strikes are done because he
thinks it would be
um disrespectful or whatever so um so
um but here's what he has said if I want
to do a hard reboot can I I remember
that and I
respect the question
and from a Creator creative person just
it's just sort of testing boundaries
what can I do what can't I do where
where we are sure but if he is actually
asking that question from a
um point of view that he's actually
thinking that's the way to go then we
need to we need to get together and hunt
him down
right
that's the point of these videos I mean
you and I are having a intelligent
conversation discussing possibilities we
should spread and I try and do it with
my own spread it you hope that it's
going to get to the right people it's
social media let's be using that the
right way and say
get your ego out of it you know Stargate
is not broken it doesn't need to be
fixed you don't need to mess with the
formula please we you're going to be the
director that doesn't mean you have to
Zack Snyder this sucker and you've got a
respect what came before or don't get on
board right I mean Zack Snyder is a
perfect example he didn't care about the
superheroes he just wanted to do his
movie so he goes against who they are he
has Batman and Superman killing people
well from that point forward you're done
you don't care about the subject
material if this director whoever he may
be or she
respects and understands what he's
getting into and we can all relax we can
all
yeah just just don't pee on the universe
if it follows through because you never
know with these things it can even if he
even if this person wants to be signed
on it that doesn't necessarily mean
until filming starts or even even after
three filming you never know these
things can change but I do think the
person that looks like he might be
involved
is a big sci-fi guy
is respectful
I think has a relationship I want I
can't say too much there has a
relationship with people that came
before sure
I think I'm okay with that and
um
and has done some very interesting
work
great but there are also negatives
that I'm not so sure about but
um I think with the right
I say I'm excited about a movie on one
hand because I think
Star Trek can't get a cinema movie
from a point of view of like it shows
that Amazon are actually serious about
this so I like that
they're going you know what we we
actually think this could be a big
franchise and the best way to start that
franchise is by a big movie and we want
to that's what we want to do we want to
get it in cinemas even if that's a bit
old-fashioned
that's because we believe in this so I
like that
I think it's a massive risk because God
knows what's going on in cinemas at the
moment I actually think we're in real
serious trouble with losing a lot of
Cinemas over the next 10 years but um if
they don't think how to reimagine
themselves
um but as long as then that series comes
pretty quick and maybe other movies and
other you know
um but I like that they seem to be
supporting it and that that fills me
with a warmth and if again the guy
that I'll tell you about in a minute
um is is true false through he's an
up-and-coming director that is getting a
lot of attention and again it shows that
they're really serious
and that should be that should warm our
cockles a little bit and then you've
proven my point of why I always tune in
because you give me as you give me the
real straight uh oh but you also give us
hope like you're telling us relax things
aren't dead in the water you know
that that anybody else who would say
something I'd be like you're you're
click bait that's garbage but you can
get it straight I appreciate that oh I
got accused of being clickbaity all the
time and I was like no the title is just
but well the video is about it's not my
fault that's what the video is about and
it makes people click as long as you
deliver it's not clickbait yeah exactly
and I just think that like sometimes
you've got to be a little bit clickbaity
because sometimes you know you want
video people to watch the video you want
it to be interesting
but yeah they've always been the problem
is though you get you know you get a
channel that's I mean the good eyes are
still a tiny Channel compared to you
know a lot of channels but we got like
26 000 subscribers or something
um so um and that will attract some
people it will just go no you're talking
crap and I have a nemesis I've got a
nemesis from day one who still calls me
a liar to this day it doesn't matter how
many times I get things right and how
many tons of the people come out and say
that you know this is happening this
happened it doesn't matter
um everything you say nothing you said
has come true
I could list it but we will leave at
them I've learned the power of the block
button it saves me a whole lot of
aggravation just the ignore button is
quite good so they just you just ignore
them from the channel but but actually
today I got to a point now where I I
just I just let them get out of it
and as long as they're not investing
they don't attack anyone else if so if
they start attacking other people in the
comments and I see it I don't read I I
would love to um
your mother
um so um you know it's
I don't I can't read most of my comments
now because you know we get hundreds of
comments since I I skim through and see
if something's interesting but I can't
um
but so unless something points out or
somebody points out this guy is being
and then they just yeah I think I've
blocked maybe three people ever through
my mental health that is the best I I
learned from I had a guest on uh Jen
Chapin Harry Chapin's daughter was on
the never gets old podcast like second
episode and she gave me one of the best
pieces of advice
ignore
a lot of the YouTube comments because
people will hate just for the sake of
hating they'll be negative yes for the
sake of being negative you know and and
also my Nemesis you gotta go with me and
call me a liar um I can't remember what
the video was because
dude that's not room eh like oh I got
one guy Evan got me for the Joe Flanagan
video I did recently sure and okay no
it's not a rumor he sits right now there
are clips of him saying it
no it's in the video it's the proof is
right this is basically reposting proof
and adding our comments that we go yeah
wouldn't that have been great
I remember when that happened too I
remember I was like
Joe Flanagan who who I've met and is a
sweet wonderful guy I'm like he okay if
you can't get Brad get yeah sure it's
part of the family let him
Do It
um I would have looked Christine what he
had in mind
I don't know I think it quite got that
far but it would have been very
interesting did you know he was in scene
as well see you met you here
through the second season so David to
you lets in it at the moment my wife my
wife watched it and she loves it but
again she's a Stargate person so yeah
that and Tom mice and who we love from
Sleepy Hollow he would he was in it so
she's like oh we've got to watch this
you know did you watch Sleepy Hollow
my wife won't watch it
we loved it but that was the perfect
example of the second and third season
had problems because they kept getting
different show Runners who wanted to
change stuff
so it contradict what happened in the
first season
you're like ah you're messing up you
know and then by the last season the
fourth season it was great again it was
perfect and then it was gone it's like
popcorn that is so wrong right he's so
so wrong promise of Amanda's on my
[__] account no
she is a lady that's right that's right
and a classy one I love her I admire her
I I you know originally watched Stargate
I'm like yeah Sam's fine but then once
you see Amanda you go I love Amanda
she's funny and she's quick
all she has to do is smile and I'm just
like
yeah she has one of those faces of her
whole face Smiles no it's warm
um yeah you see your interviews and yeah
she is very intelligent she's she's a
very bright lady super sweet and funny
she's so funny and another way of
bringing it back and I know again they
discussed this but I think plans have
sort of got bigger when it was going to
be a series there were serious
conversations about bringing Amanda back
as a showrunner
um or as least as an executive producer
and then here as well a little bit and
those conversations but I think I don't
the movie makes it a different kettle of
fish sure in these people's minds and
again I think that's one of the reasons
why Brad hasn't had the phone call but
he should have done oh and there's still
time we don't know what the future
brings let's wrap up the the strike and
then you know we can get back on board
with all the the solid stuff and I mean
they they may do the movie and then
bring him back for the series or they
may just bring him up but I actually
think if they start moving down the road
with the movie and they do get a lot of
negativity online do not be surprised if
halfway through all of a sudden Brad
Brad Wright is talking about it or Brad
Wright's involved in some way
because they're not stupid right and
however many people talk about Amazon
being this or Amazon being that they're
business people they do not like me
losing money and they really do not like
what happens with rings of power
right but they're too deep in with rings
of ponos they have to follow through
with it
that's why like on Twitter there is
though you know save Stargate or we want
Stargate
um Paul malozi had had done that I had
him on the podcast to try and help
promote hey Amazon hey Amazon because
they didn't do anything for years and
they never responded we never gotta we
hear you which if they had just said we
hear you Amazon don't do that right oh
the other Studios mine and they will
reach out to people
um Amazon genuinely don't
um and I I know for a fact Amazon have
um a lot of people because I've spoken
to one of them
um that does all they do is they look at
social media and they look at
demographics
I know for a fact and a memo went round
to the MGM employee saying whoever's
talking stop it yes I remember you
mentioning that I loved it I just loved
I wish I wanted to put the email up when
I put the guy emailed me I wanted to put
it up but I thought now I better know
how to make you feel like okay so I'm
right I'm like I'm hearing legitimate
stuff once you see that you're like okay
good faith in what I'm hearing yeah yeah
well the nice thing with me so that I've
got one source that um I trust that's
been able to put me on touch with a few
other people and but the ones that I've
been able to verify exactly who he is so
once you know that one person is
trustworthy and gives you good
information it makes it a lot easier
then to go right I know this guy who I
then don't have to go through the
process of like vetting somebody new
sure I just got my God I only said his
name then Jesus Christ so that person
just says no this guy knows what he's on
about and this this this girl knows what
she's on about and this person was in
the room so they definitely know what
they're on about and so he does a lot of
like the the vet in for me and so I just
got insanely lucky with one person
basically yeah
a little bit of a group but then MGM
happened and a lot of them got sacked so
now I've got people that work at Warner
Brothers and think that will that will
tell me stuff occasionally even I'll go
occasionally something will happen then
I'll get an email going
um I told you about that six months ago
why didn't you say anything about it I
remember that too he's so pissing me off
you didn't and at the same time you're
so good about keeping your mouth shut
not giving away your sources which would
be suicide I think but you know that
nobody would talk to me again right and
you're very respectful and you that's
crucial I don't even tell Harris and
Matt knows a couple of the sources I
speak to because he's based on my
partner in this thing now
um but Harrison stormy I don't I don't
tell them where it's come from just
because I think if you start telling
people
you're getting a habit of it yeah yeah
and it's I just think it's um it's a
good idea not but I don't need it anyway
but we've got a WhatsApp group
um which we could it's called the
sneakies that's what they call that I
don't know why they're called sneakies
um and that's the sneakies group and
they sort of put stuff on there
occasionally but yeah right Mac
I think this has been an absolute
conversation you are definitely coming
back if you are are willing anytime
um
several times
I'm not happy you disagreed with me
several times but other than that you've
been in absolute Bliss hey I need people
to tell me now well again it's not it's
not about winning it's about we're all
part of the same family we're all we all
want the same thing and we're swapping
ideas to give them uh straight you know
the facts yeah and I have a bit of a
giggle along the way is the main thing
exactly remember
[Music]
we're talking about a TV show not global
warming or something not hearing cancer
we're just trying to make you happy yeah
exactly and that's why we ever said oh
we do get people
we've seen a little bit of a problem
recently on my on the lives on a Sunday
that we keep end up talking about a
certain butt plugs I don't know how it
started but it's not going away
yeah and it needs to kind of scared that
that ever happened to begin with I don't
know how it happened I can't remember if
anybody can tell me which episode where
that starts because I'll have to click
it because I can't remember how it
happened
um but it needs to stop but we do have a
laugh and sometimes some people will get
angry at us because you're talking about
you're just being silly I'm like yeah
because we're having a laugh calm down
this is about fun it's about making the
life the world better
you know like that's my whole thing I
don't want negativity on any of my shows
I just I want to promote the good and
celebrate it yeah exactly and that's
what we want and we want some positivity
out there because there's way too much
negativity way too much even another
conversation oh god
um yeah
we'll have that conversation one of the
days thank you so so much it's been
absolutely um you've been an absolute
gent please guys everyone in the
comments and everyone watching we've got
87 people watching right now which is a
great way to have a hundred a little in
10 or 15 minutes ago so
um please get into the um description go
over to Mac's Channel and check it out
subscribe
please use these videos listen to the um
to the you know the the podcast on the
um the stories he's creating
and um and yeah and have some fun with
it please do it for you
exactly I do it for me first
what what video I was talking to
somebody who's on one of the other
channels I won't say which because it's
not fair because I need to I need a
video that's going to get some views I
don't know what to don't know what to do
because why don't you just do a video
you want just do something you want to
talk about because yeah but the
demographics and another thing and then
any other the YouTube things who cares
just don't do videos for YouTube right
right I do this because I'm passionate
about it and I want to celebrate good
things I don't make a scent
yeah but if people will and watch it and
enjoy or listen to it it's worth it good
and Philip as happy what's the channel
name tell us again yeah there's a link
in the description there's I have a hub
an actual website but I also have the
YouTube page uh it's called the forever
Adventure Network and within that is the
MacGyver podcast the MacGyver sg1 audio
series uh the never gets old podcast
Plus stores and blogs and you know music
um
anything you want to entertain yourself
is basically my goal I want to have it
diverse and a it's an us thing it's not
a me thing so if you wait that's exactly
the same as a Squidward Community I'll
tell you about something in a minute but
this is where we me and Matt were
telling somebody recently they asked us
why do we do what we do and what is our
goal our goal is to make our community
happy we talk about stuff we know our
community want to talk about and we talk
about stuff that we want to talk about
because we're like you guys this isn't I
don't do YouTube I'm not a YouTuber
I do a bit of YouTube but um you know I
I'm a I'm a Sci-Fi than that yes there's
more to you than that I'm a Sci-Fi fan
that just thought I'm gonna go on there
and talk because I like talking
talking's fun even though it's quite
hard actually but anyway guys thank you
so so much Mac um Everybody in the Audi
thank you so much for all the comments
have been absolutely amazing you're
absolute Legends
um
say goodbye Mac until next time goodbye
Mac until next time or I mean thanks
again tomorrow talking a little bit more
about the
um potential Jason Momoa ID and why
again it's a bad one apparently but see
you tomorrow guys
foreign
[Music]